a sea of candlelight illuminated the
night at a vigil for aisha Fraser Aisha
was goodness for sana v she was gracious
dr. George Frazer as I used to sung chol
she was just committed to education
committed to children and a servant
leader and committed to the community on
Saturday November 17th
Aisha Fraser went to her sister-in-laws
house to drop off her 11 and 8 year old
daughters but shortly after her arrival
her sister-in-law called 911 to
emergency I need the police immediately
my brother is attacking Fraser's
ex-husband Lance Mason a former judge
tried to flee the scene but he slammed
his SUV into a police car injuring an
officer all of this happened in minutes
they're closed before me this isn't the
first time the two young girls had seen
their father attack their mother in 2014
the girls were in the car when he beat
their mother breaking so many bones in
her face she had to have reconstructive
surgery
Mason pled guilty lost his judgeship and
had his law license suspended but he was
released from prison after nine months
of his two-year sentence the greatest
number of injuries caused to women is by
domestic violence in the u.s. one in
four women is the victim of domestic
violence which accounts for 15% of all
violent crime
her family and friends hope this is a
wake-up call for the issue of domestic
violence he took another person's life
in front of his children
I cannot think of anything wrong vile